- أهلاً بكم مجدداً في سلسلة
فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية.
اسمي John Watrous، وأنا
المدير التقني لتعليم IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس الرابع في السلسلة وهو الدرس الأخير
في الوحدة الأولى من السلسلة حول أساسيات
المعلومات الكمية.
حتى الآن، تحدثنا عن
كيفية عمل المعلومات الكمية لكل من الأنظمة المفردة والمتعددة، وألقينا نظرة على
نموذج الدوائر الكمية،
ولاحظنا بعض
القيود الأساسية على المعلومات الكمية.
وفي أثناء ذلك،
صادفنا بعض المفاهيم الرياضية المهمة
بما في ذلك حاصل الضرب التنسوري وحاصل الضرب الداخلي، وسنستمر
في استخدام هذه المفاهيم وسنقدم مفاهيم
جديدة أيضاً حسب الحاجة.
في هذا الدرس، سنركز
على ثلاثة أمثلة أساسية مهمة: النقل الآني الكمي، والترميز فائق الكثافة، ولعبة CHSH،
والتي تُسمى أيضاً متباينة CHSH ولا تُوصف دائماً كلعبة.
هذه ليست مجرد أمثلة
عشوائية لتوضيح كيفية عمل المعلومات الكمية، بل هي حقاً أجزاء
أساسية من البنية التحتية
للمعلومات الكمية
وتظهر في سياقات مختلفة وأحياناً غير متوقعة ضمن المعلومات الكمية
والحوسبة.
يلعب التشابك الكمي دوراً محورياً في هذه الأمثلة
الثلاثة جميعها، وفي الواقع، التشابك هو ما يجعلها تعمل
ويجعلها مثيرة للاهتمام. لذا، سيكون هذا الدرس، بمعنى ما، أول فرصة لنا
لرؤية التشابك الكمي عملياً
ولنبدأ في استكشاف ما الذي يجعل التشابك مثيراً للاهتمام.
نظرة عامة على
الدرس بسيطة جداً، سنمر واحداً تلو الآخر
على الأمثلة الثلاثة التي ذكرتها للتو:
النقل الآني الكمي،
والترميز فائق الكثافة، ولعبة CHSH.
سنناقش ماهية هذه الأشياء وما الذي يجعلها مثيرة للاهتمام وسنمر بتحليلات تشرح بالضبط كيف تعمل
على المستوى الرياضي.
قبل أن نصل إلى المثال الأول
من الأمثلة الثلاثة، وهو النقل الآني الكمي، من المناسب أولاً
تقديم الشخصيات،
Alice وBob، في حال لم
تكونوا على معرفة بهما.
Alice وBob هما اسمان
يُطلقان على كيانات أو عملاء افتراضيين في الأنظمة والبروتوكولات والألعاب،
وحقيقةً أي نوع آخر من التفاعلات قد ترغب في دراستها والتي تتضمن تبادل المعلومات.
ظهرا لأول مرة في
سياق التشفير في سبعينيات القرن الماضي، لكن
اصطلاح استخدام هذين الاسمين بهذه الطريقة أصبح شائعاً جداً
في سياق أوسع بكثير منذ ذلك الحين. الفكرة هي أن هذين
اسمان شائعان جداً، على الأقل في بعض أنحاء العالم، ويبدآن بالحرفين A وB،
ومن المريح أيضاً
الإشارة إلى Alice وBob باستخدام الضمائر "هي" و"هو" فقط من أجل الاختصار.
عادةً نتخيل أن Alice وBob في مواقع مختلفة ولديهما أهداف
مختلفة وسلوكيات مختلفة
بحسب الموضوع الذي نتحدث عنه.
على سبيل المثال، إذا كنا
نتحدث عن الاتصال، أي نقل المعلومات، فقد نقرر
أن Alice هي المرسلة
وBob هو المستقبل
لأي معلومات يتم نقلها.
أحياناً يتعاون Alice وBob،
وهذا هو الشائع، لكن أحياناً
يتنافسان أو قد تكون لديهما أهداف مختلفة قد تكون
أو لا تكون متوافقة
مع بعضها البعض، لكن هذا
كله يجب توضيحه في السياق المعني.
بالطبع، هما يمثلان تجريدات وليس بالضرورة بشراً حقيقيين.
يمكننا أيضاً تقديم
شخصيات إضافية مثل Charlie و
Diane أو أسماء مختلفة تمثل شخصيات مختلفة
مثل Eve
للمتنصت أو Mallory لشخص يتصرف بشكل خبيث
حسب السياق.
على أي حال، سنرى Alice وBob في الأمثلة
الثلاثة التي سنناقشها في هذا الدرس ومن وقت لآخر
خلال بقية السلسلة. سأقدم أيضاً بعض
التعليقات حول التشابك الكمي قبل الانتقال إلى الأمثلة الثلاثة.
في الدرس الثاني، صادفنا هذا المثال لحالة متشابكة من اثنين من الـ qubit.
إنها واحدة من حالات Bell الأربع، ويمكنك القول إن
هذه الحالة بالذات تمثل المثال النموذجي
لحالة كمية متشابكة.
صادفنا أيضاً هذا
المثال لحالة احتمالية من بتّين اثنين.
إنها مشابهة للحالة
المتشابكة بمعنى ما، لكنها ليست متشابكة،
فالتشابك هو ظاهرة
كمية فريدة،
بحكم التعريف بشكل أساسي.
هناك تعريف رياضي دقيق لماهية التشابك وما يقوله هذا التعريف
بشكل أساسي هو أن التشابك
هو ارتباط كمي غير كلاسيكي.
لكن هذا ليس مفيداً جداً
على المستوى الحدسي، إنه تعريف للتشابك من حيث ما ليس عليه التشابك،
وربما لهذا السبب
يكون من الصعب فعلاً شرح ماهية التشابك وما يجعله مميزاً
بمصطلحات حدسية.
عندما يحاول الناس
شرح ماهية التشابك بمصطلحات حدسية،
غالباً ما تسمع تفسيرات لا تميز حقاً
بين هاتين الحالتين
بشكل ذي معنى. قد تسمع فكرة
أنك إذا قست أحد الـ qubit المتشابكين،
فإن حالة الآخر
تتأثر بشكل فوري بطريقة ما، أو أن حالة الـ qubit الاثنين لا يمكن وصفها بشكل منفصل
أو أن الـ qubit الاثنين
يحتفظان بذاكرة عن بعضهما بطريقة ما أو حتى أنهما
مرتبطان عاطفياً بشكل ما.
لكن لماذا لا تنطبق هذه الخصائص
على هذه الحالة؟
هذان البتّان مرتبطان ارتباطاً وثيقاً، كل واحد منهما لديه
ذاكرة مثالية عن الآخر بالمعنى الحرفي، لكن
هذه ليست حالة متشابكة.
حسناً، إحدى الطرق لشرح ما
يجعل التشابك مميزاً وما يجعل هذه الحالة
مختلفة جداً عن تلك الحالة هي شرح ما يمكننا
فعله بالتشابك
أو ما يمكننا رؤيته يحدث
بسبب التشابك يتجاوز القرارات التي نتخذها حول كيفية تمثيل
معرفتنا باستخدام المتجهات.
الأمثلة الثلاثة التي
سنناقشها في هذا الدرس لها هذه الطبيعة من حيث أنها توضح
أشياء يمكننا فعلها بالتشابك لا يمكننا
فعلها بهذه الحالة
أو بأي حالة مرتبطة كلاسيكياً.
في الواقع، من الشائع جداً في دراسة المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية أن ننظر إلى التشابك كمورد
يمكن من خلاله إنجاز
مهام مختلفة.
وعندما نفعل ذلك، ننظر إلى هذه الحالة على أنها تمثل
وحدة واحدة من التشابك.
نشير إلى وحدة التشابك
هذه بـ e-bit، حيث يرمز حرف e إلى
متشابك أو تشابك.
صحيح أنهما اثنان من الـ qubit، لكن كمقدار من
التشابك، فهي e-bit واحدة.
يمكنك أيضاً النظر إلى زوج
من البتات الكلاسيكية العادية في الحالة
الاحتمالية المرتبطة التي رأيناها سابقاً على أنها مورد وهو
بت واحد من العشوائية المشتركة.
يمكن أن يكون مفيداً جداً في
التشفير أن تشارك بتاً عشوائياً مع شخص ما بافتراض
أن لا أحد غيركما يعرف قيمة هذا البت حتى يمكن
استخدامه كمفتاح خاص
أو كجزء من مفتاح خاص، على سبيل المثال، لغرض التشفير.
لكن في هذا الدرس، سيكون تركيزنا على هذه الحالة المتشابكة و
الأشياء التي يمكننا فعلها بها.
ولتوضيح المصطلحات، عندما نقول إن Alice
وBob يتشاركان e-bit، نعني أن
Alice لديها qubit اسمه A،
وBob لديه qubit اسمه B، ومعاً الزوج A وB
في حالة Phi plus.
ليس مهماً ما هي الأسماء
التي نختارها للـ qubit الاثنين، بالطبع يمكننا
اختيار أسماء مختلفة، لكن خلال هذا الدرس
سنلتزم بهذه الأسماء
من أجل الوضوح. المثال الأول في الدرس
هو النقل الآني الكمي،
والذي سنشير إليه فيما بعد
بالنقل الآني فقط من أجل الاختصار.
النقل الآني هو بروتوكول يسمح للمرسل
بنقل معلومات كمية إلى المستقبل باستخدام التشابك فقط
والاتصال الكلاسيكي
لإنجاز عملية النقل.
ليس له أي علاقة على الإطلاق بالتفسير المعتاد
لكلمة النقل الآني في الخيال العلمي، وهو
أن المادة تختفي
من مكان وتظهر في مكان آخر.
النقل الآني الكمي هو مجرد اسم يُقصد به استحضار تلك الصورة كمجاز إن صح التعبير.
ما يُنقل آنياً هو
المعلومات الكمية وليس المادة، وذلك يحدث
من خلال نقل معلومات كلاسيكية
مع التشابك.
لفهم كيفية عمل
النقل الآني بالضبط، من المفيد البدء
بتهيئة المسرح، كما يُقال.
ما سنفعله هو تخيل سيناريو يتضمن Alice وBob و
هذا السيناريو هو كالتالي،
لدى Alice qubit اسمه Q
تريد نقله إلى Bob، بمعنى أنها
تريد أن يحمل Bob بين يديه
qubit في نفس الحالة
التي يكون عليها Q عند بدء البروتوكول.
بعبارة أخرى، نتحدث عن المشكلة الأساسية
لنقل المعلومات أو الاتصال.
لدينا مرسلة اسمها Alice
ومستقبل اسمه Bob وتريد Alice إرسال
معلومات كمية في شكل qubit إلى Bob.
هناك قيد مع ذلك، وهو أن Alice غير
قادرة على إرسال Q فعلياً إلى Bob، كل ما يمكنها فعله هو إرسال معلومات كلاسيكية إلى Bob.
لدى Alice وBob أيضاً
مورد إضافي، وهو أنهما يتشاركان e-bit.
هذا هو السيناريو، من
السهل تخيل مواقف يكون فيها القيد بأن
Alice لا تستطيع إرسال Q فعلياً
إلى Bob تجريداً معقولاً.
لو كان Alice وBob على
قارات مختلفة مثلاً، أو لو لم تكن Alice تعرف
موقع Bob بالضبط، فإن إرسال qubit فعلياً
سيكون على الأرجح صعباً جداً.
لكن الاتصال الكلاسيكي
ليس ممكناً فحسب بل غير مكلف أيضاً
في ظل هذه الظروف.
الآن، قد يتساءل المرء عما إذا كان بإمكان Alice وBob إنجاز هذه المهمة دون الحاجة حتى إلى e-bit المشتركة.
بعبارة أخرى، هل هناك
أي طريقة لنقل qubit باستخدام الاتصال
الكلاسيكي وحده؟
الإجابة هي لا، لا يمكن نقل معلومات كمية باستخدام الاتصال الكلاسيكي وحده، وهذا ليس صعب الإثبات
باستخدام بعض نظريات المعلومات
الكمية الأساسية، والتي سنراها في
الوحدة الثالثة من السلسلة.
في الوقت الحالي، طريقة
حدسية للتفكير في الأمر هي التفكير في نظرية عدم الاستنساخ.
تخيل أنه كانت هناك طريقة
لإرسال معلومات كمية باستخدام الاتصال الكلاسيكي وحده،
لكن الاتصال الكلاسيكي
يمكن نسخه وبثه بسهولة، وهذا يعني
أن الاتصال الكلاسيكي
يمكن بثه إلى مستقبلَين
اثنين، Bob وCharlie، لنقل.
لو أن كليهما تلقى
نفس المعلومات الكلاسيكية من Alice، فهل
سينتهي الأمر بكليهما بامتلاك Q؟
هذا يوحي بأننا استنسخنا Q، لكننا نعلم أن ذلك مستحيل.
كملاحظة جانبية، دعونا
نلاحظ أنه بالتأكيد من الممكن وصف
متجهات الحالة الكمية باستخدام معلومات كلاسيكية.
كل متجه حالة كمية
ستشاهدونه في السلسلة يتم وصفه لكم
باستخدام معلومات كلاسيكية تم نقلها إلى أي
جهاز تشاهدون عليه.
بشكل عام، يمكننا تخيل
وصف أي حالة يكون عليها Q باستخدام بتات كلاسيكية
ربما بدقة معينة،
لكن هذا ليس اتصالاً كمياً، هذا مجرد وصف
للحالات الكمية كمتجهات، وسنعود إلى
التمييز بينهما
بعد لحظات.
بالعودة إلى السيناريو مع ذلك، والعمل تحت
افتراض أن Alice وBob يتشاركان e-bit، سنرى
أن Alice وBob
لديهما كل ما يحتاجانه
لإنجاز المهمة، وهذا ما يفعله بروتوكول النقل
الآني الكمي، وتحديداً باستخدام بتّين
من الاتصال الكلاسيكي.
قبل الخوض في
هذه التفاصيل، مع ذلك، دعوني أقدم بعض
الملاحظات السريعة فقط للتأكد من وضوح الافتراضات.
أولاً، نفترض
هنا أن حالة Q غير معروفة لـ Alice و
Bob، لذا بشكل خاص،
لا تستطيع Alice إرسال وصف
للحالة Q إلى Bob لأنها لا تعرفها بشكل عام.
يجب علينا أيضاً النظر في احتمال أن Q مرتبط بأنظمة أخرى، بما في ذلك احتمال
أنه متشابك
مع أنظمة أخرى و
نقل هذا الـ qubit إلى Bob يجب أن يحافظ على تلك الارتباطات.
أخيراً، ذكرت
نظرية عدم الاستنساخ عندما كنت أتحدث عن
محاولة نقل الـ qubit كلاسيكياً، لكن
هناك صلة أخرى هنا
مع نظرية عدم الاستنساخ، وهي أنه إذا
تلقى Bob نقل هذا الـ qubit Q من Alice،
فيجب ألا يكون لديها بعد ذلك
لأنه لا يمكن استنساخ Q، وهذا شيء يجب تذكره
عند دراسة بروتوكول النقل الآني.
يمكن وصف بروتوكول النقل
الآني بطريقة بسيطة ومباشرة جداً باستخدام مخطط circuit كمي كما ترون هنا.
إنه منمّق قليلاً من حيث
أنه يصور الفصل بين جزء Alice وجزء Bob، لكن بخلاف ذلك، إنه مجرد
مخطط circuit كمي،
كل شيء فوق الخط المنقط
يمثل أفعال Alice وكل شيء تحته
يمثل أفعال Bob.
الزمن يسير من اليسار إلى اليمين كالمعتاد، ونرى أننا نبدأ
بهذين الـ qubit هنا في حالة Phi plus،
وهذه هي الـ e-bit
التي يبدأ بها Alice وBob.
يمكننا وضع تسميات على الـ qubit لتوضيح أيها
أيّ، فهذا هو الـ qubit A، وهذا هو الـ qubit
B اللذان يشكلان الـ e-bit،
وهذا هو الـ qubit Q الذي
تريد Alice نقله إلى Bob.
هنا نفترض أن
حالة هذا الـ qubit Q هي Psi، لكن بعد قليل سننظر في احتمال
أن Q متشابك
مع نظام آخر. وما يدّعيه المخطط لأننا كتبنا psi هنا في الأسفل،
هو أن هذه الـ circuit
تنقل فعلياً أي حالة psi كانت لدينا
هنا في جزء Alice إلى هنا في جزء Bob،
والاتصال الوحيد
الذي يعبر الخط
بين Alice وBob هو البتّان الكلاسيكيان
اللذان يمثلهما هذان الخطان المزدوجان هنا.
دعونا نصغّر هذا
المخطط قليلاً حتى يكون لدينا مساحة أكبر ودعونا نفحص
الـ circuit عن كثب.
لقد وصفت بالفعل
الشروط الأولية، لكن لنلخص، تحمل Alice الـ qubit A
وBob يحمل الـ qubit B،
حيث A وB معاً
في حالة Phi plus، وهذا ما يعنيه مشاركة e-bit.
لدى Alice أيضاً هذا الـ qubit Q الذي تريد نقله إلى Bob، ونحن ننظر في حالة أن Q في حالة كمية عشوائية Psi.
الآن، لا نعرف أي شيء
عن كيف حصل Alice وBob على هذه الـ e-bit.
من الممكن أنهما
امتلكاها لفترة طويلة، ربما أنشآها قبل فترة عندما كانا في نفس الموقع
وكانا يحتفظان بها
لهذه المناسبة، لكن هذه التفاصيل ليست ذات صلة هنا.
الخطوات التي تحدث بعد ذلك، والتي تمثل
بروتوكول النقل الآني نفسه هي كالتالي، ولنكون واضحين،
هذه هي الخطوات التي
يصفها المخطط وسنكتبها
بالكلمات حتى يتضح ما
يعبّر عنه المخطط.
تقوم Alice أولاً بعملية
controlled-NOT حيث الـ qubit Q الذي
تريد إرساله إلى Bob هو المتحكم والـ
qubit A هو الهدف.
الخطوة التالية هي أنها
تقوم بعملية Hadamard على Q، ثم تقيس
الـ qubit اللذين تحملهما،
A وQ بالنسبة لقياسات
الأساس القياسي ونرمز بالحرف الصغير a لنتيجة قياس الـ qubit A،
ونرمز بالحرف الصغير b لنتيجة قياس الـ qubit Q.
ثم ترسل Alice هذين
البتّين الكلاسيكيين إلى Bob وهذا هو الاتصال الوحيد المتضمن في هذا البروتوكول وهذا موضح في المخطط
بحقيقة أن هذين
البتّين يعبران الخط المنقط بين Alice وBob،
والذي يمكنك اعتباره يمثل أي
مسافة تفصل بينهما.
بعد أن يتلقى Bob البتّين
a وb، يقوم بأمرين.
أولاً، إذا كان a يساوي واحد، فإنه يقوم بعملية X
أو بعبارة أخرى، gate NOT على الـ qubit B الخاص به،
وإلا إذا كان a يساوي صفر، فإنه لا يفعل ذلك.
وبالمثل،
إذا كان b يساوي واحد، فإن Bob يقوم بعملية Z
أو Z-gate أو قلب الطور
أيضاً على الـ qubit B ومثل
سابقاً، إذا كان b يساوي صفر، فإنه لا يفعل ذلك.
كل هذا موضح في الشكل حيث لدينا gate من نوع controlled-X
وcontrolled-Z حيث المتحكمات هي
البتّان الكلاسيكيان.
ليس عليك التفكير في هذه الـ gate على أنها بوابات تحكم
إن لم ترد، هذه مجرد طريقة مريحة
للتعبير عما نريده
في شكل مخطط circuit. المهم هو أن Bob يطبق
X-gate على الـ qubit B إذا كان a يساوي واحد و
ثم يطبق Z-gate
على الـ qubit B إذا كان b يساوي واحد.
ومن أجل الراحة لاحقاً يمكننا كتابة العملية المجمعة
التي يقوم بها Bob على الـ qubit B الخاص به بشكل صريح،
بحسب البتّين الكلاسيكيين
اللذين ترسلهما Alice.
هذا هو بروتوكول النقل الآني، إنه بسيط جداً حقاً،
حقيقة أنه يعمل فعلاً هي مسألة مختلفة
وعلى الرغم من أن التحليل
ليس معقداً جداً،
لا ينبغي أن تشعر أنك تفوّت شيئاً إذا لم تفهم فوراً لماذا يعمل.
لهذا نحتاج إلى
المرور بتحليل وهذا ما سنفعله بعد ذلك.
لتحليل بروتوكول النقل الآني، سنعمل عليه خطوة بخطوة لنرى ما هي حالات
الـ qubit الثلاثة في نقاط مختلفة من الزمن.
سننظر أولاً في
حالة أن الـ qubit العلوي في الحالة Alpha صفر زائد beta واحد، حيث alpha وbeta
هما أي عددين مركبين
يجعلان هذا المتجه
متجه وحدة.
هذا هو الـ qubit Q الذي
تحاول Alice نقله، لكننا لا نهتم حقاً بما
يُسمى في هذه اللحظة.
بعد قليل، سنلقي
نظرة على الحالة التي يكون فيها هذا الـ qubit
متشابكاً مع نظام آخر، لكن هذه نقطة
بداية جيدة لإبقاء الأمور بسيطة
ولنرى كيف يعمل التحليل
بشكل أوضح قليلاً.
إذا نظرنا إلى حالة
الـ qubit الثلاثة معاً هنا في البداية، نرى
أن هذه الحالة لها الشكل الذي ترونه هنا.
الـ qubit الأولان في
حالة Phi plus، والـ qubit الثالث هو العلوي
وفقاً لاصطلاح
ترتيب الـ qubit الذي
وصفته في الدرس السابق، ولذا نأخذ حاصل الضرب التنسوري للحصول على حالة
الـ qubit الثلاثة معاً.
يمكننا توسيع هذا التعبير
بتعويض تعريف حالة Phi plus أولاً ثم حساب حاصل الضرب التنسوري
ونحصل على الحالة
التي ترونها هنا.
ليس دائماً أفضل استراتيجية
بالمناسبة، أن توسّع
متجهاً كهذا بالكامل، من الأفضل عموماً الانتظار حتى
يكون لديك سبب وجيه لفعل ذلك.
لكن هنا لدينا سبب، وهو أننا نريد
حساب تأثير gate الـ controlled-NOT وبكتابة الحالة بهذا الشكل،
يمكننا فعل ذلك بسهولة كبيرة.
وبالتحديد، هذه هي
حالة الـ qubit الثلاثة بعد تطبيق gate الـ controlled-NOT.
الـ qubit الثالث هو qubit التحكم لأنه
الذي في الأعلى وفقاً لاصطلاحنا، والـ qubit الثاني،
وهو الأوسط،
هو الهدف، فنحن فقط
نعمل على الحالات وفقاً لذلك، إذا كان البت الثالث
صفراً، لا يحدث شيء،
وإذا كان البت الثالث واحداً،
فإننا نقلب البت الثاني.
ثم نطبق gate الـ Hadamard
على الـ qubit الثالث، ويمكننا كتابة المتجه
الناتج كما ترون
هنا بتعويض حالة
الزائد وحالة الناقص بدلاً من حالة الصفر وحالة الواحد.
وإذا أردنا أن يكون لدينا
مساحة كافية لتوسيع هذا، سنحتاج لتصغيره
قليلاً والآن، بتعويض حالتي
الزائد والناقص
بتعريفاتهما،
وإدخال الجذر التربيعي للاثنين في المقام، نحصل على الحالة التي ترونها هنا.
وبتوسيع ذلك، نحصل على الحالة التي ترونها هنا.
إذاً، هذه هي حالة الـ qubit الثلاثة بعد أن تقوم Alice بعمليتيها.
ثم تقيس Alice
وإذا أردنا تحليل القياسات، ما نفعله هو عزل متجهات الأساس القياسي
للأنظمة التي يتم قياسها
تماماً كما تحدثنا عنه في الدرس الثاني، وإذا فعلنا ذلك في هذه الحالة بالذات، هذا ما نحصل عليه.
وإذا نظرت إلى ذلك
التعبير للحظة، قد يبدو غريباً بعض الشيء لأنه يبدو الآن أن الـ qubit الأول،
وهو الـ qubit السفلي
يعتمد بطريقة ما على alpha وbeta، رغم أنه في
هذه المرحلة لم يكن هناك أي اتصال عبر الخط المنقط،
لكن هذا مجرد وهم. تذكر أن الأعداد القياسية تتحرك
بحرية عبر حواصل الضرب التنسوري، فليس هناك حقاً أي معنى
يُنسب فيه alpha وbeta
إلى الـ qubit الأول.
كل ما فعلناه حقاً
هنا هو استخدام الأقواس وفقاً لخاصية
التعدد الخطي لحواصل الضرب التنسوري.
على أي حال، هذا هو الشكل الذي نحتاجه لنرى ما يفعله القياس، ويمكننا رؤية شيء
مثير للاهتمام فوراً
وهو أن احتمالات نتائج القياس الأربعة الممكنة دائماً متساوية.
احتمال قياس كل
زوج من نتائج القياس هو ربع، لذا بشكل خاص،
لا يوجد أي اعتماد
على الإطلاق على alpha وbeta.
يمكننا رؤية ذلك في كل حالة بحساب مربع المعيار الإقليدي لأي
متجه مضروب تنسورياً بمتجه الأساس القياسي
الذي عزلناه،
وفي كل حالة نحصل على ربع والذي نحصل عليه بتربيع نصف مضروباً في القيمة المطلقة المربعة لـ alpha
زائد القيمة المطلقة
المربعة لـ beta، وهي واحد، وهكذا نحصل على ربع في كل حالة.
من المهم جداً في
الواقع أن احتمالات هذه النتائج المختلفة لا تعتمد بأي شكل على الـ qubit الذي
تريد Alice نقله.
لا يمكن أن تدخل حالة عشوائية من هنا وتخرج من هنا ومع ذلك يكشف القياس
معلومات عن تلك الحالة.
إذا أردت الحصول على معلومات عن حالة كمية عشوائية، فستضطر إلى تشويش
تلك الحالة بشكل عام.
هذا جدول يصف ليس فقط الاحتمالات
للنتائج المختلفة، بل أيضاً حالة
الـ qubit الثلاثة معاً
مشروطة بكل نتيجة قياس
ممكنة.
نحصل على هذا بتطبيع المتجهات المضروبة تنسورياً بمتجهات
الأساس القياسي المختلفة، لكن هذا سهل في هذه الحالة،
فقط نزيل عامل النصف للحصول على متجه وحدة.
إذاً، ما لدينا فوراً
بعد قياس Alice هو أن Alice لديها بتّان عشوائيان
منتظمان وهذا كل شيء.
بشكل خاص، لم تعد تمتلك
الحالة الأصلية وليس لديها أي
معلومات عنها، لديها فقط بتات عشوائية.
حالة Bob الآن تعتمد
على alpha وbeta وكذلك على نتائج القياس.
إذا تخيلنا للحظة
أن Alice لم ترسل بعد نتائج القياس
بحيث لا يعرف Bob ما هي نتائج القياس،
فإنه لن يتمكن من
الحصول على أي معلومات عن alpha وbeta
من قياس الـ qubit الخاص به.
هذه الاحتمالات الأربعة
التي لدينا هنا مخلوطة بشكل كافٍ لضمان عدم إمكانية الحصول على أي معلومات
عن alpha وbeta
عبر أي قياس. يجب أن يكون
ذلك صحيحاً على المستوى الحدسي لأنه لولا ذلك لكان لدينا
اتصال أسرع من الضوء.
بالتأكيد لا تستطيع Alice
نقل معلومات إلى Bob دون إرسال أي شيء على الإطلاق، لكن بالطبع ترسل Alice نتائج القياس
إلى Bob، فدعونا نوسع الجدول لنرى ما يحدث عندما
يقوم Bob بعملياته.
في هذا العمود هنا، لدينا العمليات المختلفة التي يقوم بها Bob فعلياً لكل من النتائج الممكنة
للقياسات
كما لاحظنا سابقاً،
وإذا مررنا واحدة تلو الأخرى وطبقنا تلك
العملية على qubit Bob، وهو الأول B،
نرى أننا نحصل على نفس
النتيجة في الحالات الأربع جميعها وتلك النتيجة هي الحالة الأصلية.
إذاً، الحالة الأصلية للـ qubit Q تم نقلها آنياً بنجاح إلى B.
إذا أراد Bob إعادة تسمية الـ qubit الخاص به وتسميته Q في هذه المرحلة، فمرحباً به، لكن المهم هو أنه الآن
يحمل الحالة الأصلية
التي كانت لدى Alice وبالطبع بالضرورة، لم تعد Alice تمتلكها.
لاحظ أيضاً أن الـ e-bit
قد استُهلكت فعلياً خلال هذه العملية،
للنقل الآني تكلفة
والتكلفة هي e-bit واحدة وبتّان كلاسيكيان من الاتصال، وعندما ينتهي البروتوكول
تكون الـ e-bit قد اختفت.
لقد أثبتنا الآن أن
بروتوكول النقل الآني يعمل بشكل صحيح تحت افتراض أن الـ qubit العلوي في حالة كمية
من الشكل alpha مضروباً في حالة
الصفر زائد beta مضروباً في حالة الواحد.
لكن ماذا يحدث إذا كان
الـ qubit العلوي متشابكاً مع نظام آخر مثل
بعض الـ qubit الإضافية
كما نرى هنا على الشاشة؟ قد نرغب في استخدام النقل الآني
في ظل هذه الظروف.
ربما يخطط Alice وBob فعلاً
لتنفيذ النقل الآني 100 مرة حتى تتمكن Alice من نقل
سجل كمي من 100 qubit
إلى Bob، qubit واحد في كل مرة.
أو ربما هذه الـ qubit
الإضافية ليست حتى في حوزة Alice
على الإطلاق وشخص آخر يمتلكها، ربما Alice لا
تعلم حتى بوجودها.
السؤال هو، هل
يعمل النقل الآني حتى لو كان الـ qubit المنقول آنياً متشابكاً مع نظام آخر؟
هنا، حالة الـ qubit Q مع النظام الإضافي
الذي ننظر فيه معبّر عنها كما ترون هنا
حيث gamma صفر و
gamma واحد هما متجهات وحدة تمثل حالات كمية
لهذا النظام الإضافي.
يمكننا دائماً كتابة حالة عشوائية للنظام المركب بهذه الطريقة.
نحن فعلاً لا نحتاج
حتى إلى alpha وbeta هنا، لكن إذا أدرجناهما،
فيمكننا اعتبار gamma صفر وgamma واحد متجهات وحدة
وهذا سيجعل الصلة
بالحالة الأبسط التي نظرنا فيها بالفعل أكثر وضوحاً.
يمكننا المرور بتحليل
مشابه للذي مررنا به بالفعل، لكن مع تتبع
هذا النظام الإضافي أيضاً.
الأمر أكثر فوضوية قليلاً بسبب النظام الإضافي، لكن
الفكرة هي نفسها تماماً، إليكم ملخص سريع جداً.
هذه هي الحالة الأولية، وهذه هي الحالة بعد
gate الـ controlled-NOT،
وهذه هي الحالة بعد
عملية Hadamard.
إذا وسّعنا هذه الأشياء،
يمكننا التعبير عن تلك الحالة كما ترون هنا،
هذه هي الحالة مباشرة
قبل قياسات Alice، وإذا مررنا بالاحتمالات
تماماً كما فعلنا سابقاً
ونظرنا فيما
يحدث عندما يطبق Bob أي عملية من المفترض أن يطبقها،
فسنجد أن الحالة
الصحيحة تخرج فعلاً والبروتوكول يعمل كما هو متوقع.
في هذا الجدول بالمناسبة، نستخدم الحرف R للإشارة
إلى هذا النظام الإضافي، ويمكنكم ملاحظة أننا
نستخدم حيلة بسيطة جداً،
وهي أن نقرر أننا نفضل، على الأقل مؤقتاً، ترتيب
الأنظمة كـ B، R، A، Q
لأن ذلك أكثر ملاءمة لكتابة الحالات هنا.
وفقاً للمخطط، يجب أن تكون الأنظمة
مرتبة كـ B، A، Q، R،
لكن طالما نوضح ذلك، يمكننا اختيار ترتيب
مختلف أكثر ملاءمة.
باختصار، كل ما يحدث في هذا التحليل هو
نفس ما حدث في التحليل الأبسط،
لكن يصادف أن لدينا
هذه المتجهات الإضافية، gamma صفر وgamma واحد
التي تأتي بشكل أساسي مع الرحلة.
لدينا دائماً gamma صفر
عندما يكون هناك عامل alpha وgamma واحد عندما
يكون هناك عامل beta وفي نهاية المطاف،
كل شيء يعمل بشكل صحيح.
هذا في الواقع ليس مفاجئاً على الإطلاق، لدينا عملية فيزيائية تعمل كعملية الهوية
على qubit
في حالة كمية عشوائية، وهناك طريقة واحدة فقط
يمكن أن يحدث بها ذلك وهي أن العملية
هي عملية الهوية.
هذا أسهل قليلاً في الشرح باستخدام الصياغة العامة
للمعلومات الكمية، لكن المهم هو أنه بحكم الخطية،
لم نكن فعلاً بحاجة للمرور بهذا التحليل الإضافي.
بمجرد أن نعرف أن
النقل الآني يعمل بشكل صحيح لـ qubit واحد بمعزل، يمكننا الاستنتاج أن هناك
شيئاً واحداً فقط ممكناً
يمكن أن يصف ما يفعله البروتوكول، وهو أنه ينفذ
عملية الهوية حيث يدخل qubit من هنا
ويخرج من هنا، ليعمل فعلياً كقناة كمية
مثالية خالية من الضوضاء.
بعض الملاحظات السريعة
عن النقل الآني قبل الانتقال إلى
المثال الثاني في الدرس، وهو الترميز فائق الكثافة.
أولاً، أعتقد أنه من المهم التوضيح أن النقل الآني ليس تطبيقاً للمعلومات الكمية، إنه بروتوكول
وتحديداً هو بروتوكول
لإجراء الاتصال الكمي.
لكي يكون النقل الآني
كما وصفته مفيداً، يجب أن يكون هناك سبب لإجراء الاتصال الكمي.
ثانياً، من المعقول التكهن بأن النقل الآني يمكن أن يصبح، يوماً
ما، طريقة معيارية
لنقل المعلومات الكمية، وتحديداً عملية تُعرف بتقطير التشابك
قد تُستخدم
كطريقة لنقل الـ qubit بشكل موثوق. إذا علم Alice وBob أنهما
سيتبادلان معلومات كمية أو كانت لديهما
الحاجة لتبادل
معلومات كمية، فيمكن استخدام عملية تقطير التشابك
هذه لتحويل عدد أكبر من e-bit المشوشة
إلى عدد أقل من
e-bit عالية الجودة يمكن استخدامها بعد ذلك لنقل آني خالٍ من الضوضاء أو شبه خالٍ منها.
الفكرة هي أن عملية
تقطير التشابك ليست حساسة بنفس القدر بمعنى ما، يمكننا قبول الخسائر و
إذا لم تنجح،
فيمكننا ببساطة المحاولة مرة أخرى، بينما الـ qubit الفعلية التي
نريد نقلها قد تُعتبر أثمن بكثير.
بالطبع، هذا كله تكهنات، لكن المهم هو أنه ليس من الصعب افتراض مواقف
يمكن فيها للنقل الآني
أن يكون طريقة عملية جداً
لنقل الـ qubit.
والنقطة الأخيرة
بخصوص النقل الآني هي أن الفكرة وراء النقل الآني وطريقة عمله
أساسية جداً
في المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية، النقل الآني هو حقاً حجر زاوية في نظرية المعلومات الكمية
وتنويعات
على الفكرة تظهر أيضاً كثيراً،
كمثال واحد فقط، هناك مقترحات
لتنفيذ gate كمية مختلفة
باستخدام النقل الآني، لكن
باختيار حالات أولية وقياسات مختلفة
بحيث تكون النتيجة
تطبيق عملية مختارة
بدلاً من الاتصال.
المثال التالي هو الترميز فائق الكثافة.
مثل النقل الآني الكمي،
الترميز فائق الكثافة هو بروتوكول وما ينجزه هو مكمّل للنقل الآني.
بينما يسمح النقل الآني
بنقل qubit واحد باستخدام e-bit وبتّين
كلاسيكيين من الاتصال،
يسمح الترميز فائق الكثافة
بنقل بتّين كلاسيكيين باستخدام
e-bit وqubit واحد من الاتصال الكمي.
باختصار، يسمح الترميز فائق الكثافة بنقل
المعلومات الكلاسيكية وسبب تسميته
بالترميز فائق الكثافة
هو أنه يسمح بتعبئة بتّين
كلاسيكيين من الاتصال في qubit واحد،
لكن يجب أن نستهلك
e-bit لإنجاز هذا.
إليكم شرح أدق
للإعداد.
مرة أخرى، لدينا Alice وBob، حيث Alice هي المرسلة
وBob هو المستقبل، وهذه المرة لدى Alice بتّان كلاسيكيان
تريد إرسالهما إلى Bob.
تستطيع Alice إرسال qubit واحد إلى Bob ويتشارك Alice وBob
e-bit يمكنهما استخدامها لمساعدتهما في إنجاز مهمتهما،
وهي أن يتلقى Bob
البتّين الكلاسيكيين.
الآن، هناك معنى قد تبدو فيه هذه المهمة أقل إثارة للاهتمام من المهمة التي
ينجزها النقل الآني،
خاصة إذا اعتبرنا
أن إرسال الـ qubit أصعب بشكل ملحوظ
أو أكثر تحدياً من إرسال بتات كلاسيكية،
وهي وجهة نظر معقولة جداً لكنه بالتأكيد مثير للاهتمام أن هذا ممكن.
أحد أسباب كونه مثيراً للاهتمام
هو أنه في الواقع مستحيل إنجاز
هذه المهمة المتمثلة في نقل بتّين كلاسيكيين من المعلومات
باستخدام qubit واحد دون
الاستفادة من الـ e-bit.
نعلم هذا بسبب نظرية شهيرة تُعرف بنظرية Holevo.
نظرية Holevo أعم
من هذا، والصياغة الدقيقة
لنظرية Holevo تقنية بعض الشيء و
تحتاج إلى بعض الشرح،
لكن إحدى نتائجها
هي أنه لا يمكنك نقل أي عدد من البتات
الكلاسيكية من الاتصال باستخدام عدد أقل من الـ qubit
من الاتصال الكمي وحده.
إذا أردت نقل بتّين كلاسيكيين من
المعلومات بشكل موثوق باستخدام qubit ولم يكن لديك
e-bit للاستفادة منها،
فستضطر لإرسال qubit اثنين، فقد يكون من الأفضل تخزين البتات التي تريد نقلها فيهما.
سبب آخر يجعل الترميز
فائق الكثافة مثيراً للاهتمام هو العلاقة
التكاملية الوثيقة التي يملكها مع النقل الآني، و
سنعود إلى هذا
بعد قليل. إليكم وصف بـ circuit كمية لبروتوكول الترميز فائق الكثافة.
لهذا البروتوكول، لن
أسرد كل الخطوات، بل سنكتفي بوصف مخطط الـ circuit.
كما ترون، لدينا مرة أخرى
Alice وBob، حيث Alice في الأعلى
وBob في الأسفل.
هنا الـ e-bit التي
يتشاركها Alice وBob في البداية، والتي
تم إنشاؤها بطريقة ما قبل تشغيل البروتوكول.
لدى Alice بتّان كلاسيكيان، A وB، كما ترون هنا
ومن خلال البروتوكول الذي تصفه الـ circuit،
هذان البتّان الكلاسيكيان
سينتهيان في يد Bob.
هناك qubit واحد فقط
يعبر الخط بين Alice وBob، وبالطبع ليس هناك
أي بتات كلاسيكية تُرسل،
إن نقل البتّين
الكلاسيكيين هو الهدف من البروتوكول.
ستلاحظون أيضاً أنه يحتوي على
نفس المكونات المستخدمة في النقل الآني بالضبط، لدينا gate من نوع controlled-NOT
وgate من نوع Hadamard،
وZ وX-gate
يتحكم بهما بتات كلاسيكية.
لكنها مرتبة بشكل مختلف، فدعونا ننتقل إلى
التحليل لنرى كيف يعمل.
لتحليل كيفية عمل الترميز فائق الكثافة، دعونا نبدأ بكتابة
أساس Bell، وهو في صميم
التحليل.
ما سنفعله هو
أن ننظر أولاً إلى تأثير أفعال Alice
على حالة Phi plus، وما سنراه هو
أن Alice تحوّل هذه
الحالة Phi plus إلى واحدة
من حالات Bell الأربع حسب البتات
التي تريد إرسالها.
لذا، دعونا نكتب جدولاً حتى نتمكن من
تتبع ما يحدث.
أولاً، إذا كان A وB كلاهما صفر، فلا يتم تطبيق Z-gate ولا
X-gate، لذا أفعال Alice لا تفعل شيئاً،
أي أن Phi
plus تُربط بـ Phi plus.
يمكننا أيضاً التعبير عن ذلك كمعادلة كما ترون هنا،
لا يحدث شيء لـ qubit Alice ولا يحدث شيء لـ qubit Bob
وعدم فعل شيء يُمثَّل
بمصفوفة الهوية.
الآن، ماذا يحدث إذا كان A يساوي صفر وB يساوي واحد؟
حسناً، لأن B يساوي واحد، نطبق Z-gate و
لا نطبق X-gate لأن A يساوي صفر
ونرى أن التأثير الإجمالي هو أن Alice تطبق Z-gate.
Alice على اليمين
لأنها في الأعلى، رغم أنه لن
يحدث فرق فعلياً في هذه الحالة
بالذات، التأثير هو أن
حالة Phi plus تتحول
إلى Phi minus، ويمكنك ملاحظة ذلك
من هذه التعبيرات إذا تذكرت كيف تعمل Z-gate.
إذاً، يمكننا إضافة هذا إلى جدولنا، هناك حالتان أخريان للمرور بهما، إذا كان A يساوي واحد
وB يساوي صفر،
فإن Alice تطبق
X-gate وهذا يحول Phi plus إلى Chi plus، وإذا كان A يساوي واحد
وB يساوي واحد،
فإن Alice تطبق Z ثم
X ونحصل على Chi minus.
إذاً، جدولنا يخبرنا بما يحدث في الحالات الأربع الممكنة وهو أن Alice تختار فعلياً أي واحدة
من حالات Bell الأربع تريد
مشاركتها مع Bob، ولديها حرية الاختيار بالتصرف على الـ qubit الخاص بها وحده
وهذا جانب مثير للاهتمام
جداً في التشابك.
ثم ترسل Alice الـ qubit
الخاص بها إلى Bob، وفي هذه المرحلة، يحمل Bob واحدة من حالات Bell الأربع ويحتاج فقط
لمعرفة أي واحدة
لاسترداد البتات.
ويمكننا التحقق من أن
gate من نوع controlled-NOT متبوعة بـ gate من نوع Hadamard
كما في المخطط تعطي النتيجة الصحيحة.
لن أمر بها بالتفصيل، لكن إذا اخترت فعل ذلك، ستجد أن التأثير هو
كما ترون هنا في الجدول.
إحدى طرق التحقق من ذلك
هي ببساطة بالحساب. بدلاً من ذلك، يمكننا ملاحظة أننا في الواقع مررنا بالفعل
بهذا بالاتجاه المعاكس
في الدرس السابق. في الدرس السابق كانت
لدينا gate من نوع Hadamard أولاً وgate من نوع controlled-NOT ثانياً
ورأينا أن تلك الـ circuit
ربطت حالات الأساس القياسي بحالات Bell مع علامة
ناقص مزعجة في إحدى الحالات.
عندما نعكس ترتيب الـ gate وننظر إلى حقيقة
أن كلتا الـ gate معكوسة نفسها،
ما نحصل عليه هو المعكوس،
وبالتالي ما لدينا في هذه
الحالة هو أن التأثير يسير في الاتجاه المعاكس
وعلامة الناقص يمكنها اختيار أي
جانب تريد أن تكون عليه،
لكن بخلاف ذلك، هي في مكانها الصحيح، وعند هذه النقطة يصبح
واضحاً فوراً أن القياس يكشف القيم الصحيحة،
علامة الناقص هنا لا تزعجنا لأن الواحد يظهر
باحتمال واحد في هذه الحالة، وهذا كل ما في التحليل.
باختصار، Alice تختار حالة Bell وBob يكتشف أي واحدة هي.
بعض الملاحظات المختصرة
عن الترميز فائق الكثافة قبل الانتقال؛ أولاً، يجب أن نعترف
بأن الترميز فائق الكثافة
على الأرجح ليس مفيداً
أو عملياً بأي شكل كوسيلة
لنقل المعلومات الكلاسيكية.
الاتصال الكلاسيكي
غير مكلف جداً وإرسال الـ qubit فعلياً صعب على أقل تقدير،
وطالما أن هذا هو الحال، لا نتوقع أي
ميزة عملية على الإطلاق من الترميز فائق الكثافة.
لكن لمجرد أنه ليس من المرجح
أن يكون عملياً لا يعني أن الترميز فائق
الكثافة ليس مثيراً للاهتمام.
إنه مثير جداً للاهتمام في الواقع، فمن ناحية، الفكرة الأساسية
أساسية حقاً،
وعندما أشير إلى الفكرة الأساسية، أعني فكرة أنه إذا تشاركت Alice
حالة Bell مع Bob،
فيمكنها اختيار تغيير تلك الحالة إلى أي حالة Bell أخرى
تختارها بمفردها تماماً، لا تحتاج مساعدة Bob
على الإطلاق لفعل ذلك.
هذا مثال محدد
يخص حالات Bell، لكن هناك فكرة أساسية أعم تتعلق بالحرية التي يمتلكها أحد اللاعبين
في تحويل حالة متشابكة مشتركة مع لاعب آخر، وفهم ما هي
تلك الحرية بالضبط
هو خطوة مهمة في فهم المعلومات الكمية وسنرى بالضبط كيف نصف تلك الحرية بمصطلحات بسيطة
وأنيقة في الوحدة
الثالثة من السلسلة.
يقدم الترميز فائق الكثافة أيضاً
مثالاً ملموساً على ما يمكنك فعله بالتشابك، وهو السماح بنقل بتّين كلاسيكيين
بإرسال qubit واحد. كما ذكرت سابقاً، هذا
مستحيل بشكل مُثبت بحسب نظرية Holevo بدون التشابك.
يمكننا أيضاً النظر إلى النقل الآني والترميز فائق الكثافة معاً، ونرى أنهما
يؤسسان تكافؤاً
بين qubit واحد من الاتصال الكمي وبتّين من الاتصال الكلاسيكي.
طالما أنك مستعد
لإنفاق e-bit واحدة، يمكنك فعلياً
تحويل أحدهما إلى الآخر.
يسمح النقل الآني بنقل
qubit واحد باستخدام بتّين كلاسيكيين من الاتصال والترميز فائق الكثافة يسير بالاتجاه المعاكس
ويسمح ببتّين كلاسيكيين
من الاتصال باستخدام qubit واحد من الاتصال الكمي.
بدون إنفاق الـ e-bit مع ذلك، لا يمكنك تحويل
أي منهما إلى الآخر، التشابك هو ما
يجعل هذا ممكناً.
المثال الثالث والأخير
الذي سنغطيه في هذا الدرس ليس بروتوكولاً بل
لعبة تُعرف بلعبة CHSH.
عندما نتحدث عن لعبة في هذا السياق، لا نتحدث عن شيء يُلعب
من أجل المتعة أو الرياضة،
بل عن تجريد رياضي بمعنى نظرية الألعاب مثلاً.
التجريدات الرياضية للألعاب تُدرس بشكل شائع جداً في
الاقتصاد وعلوم الحاسوب مثلاً، وهناك
قيمة كبيرة جداً
في التجريد، فالألعاب ليست كلها متعة
في الألعاب كما يتبين،
رغم أنه من الممتع التفكير فيها.
في هذه الحالة بالذات، ما لدينا هو في الأساس
تجربة فكرية يمكن وصفها بطريقة
حدسية جداً كلعبة.
الأحرف CHSH تشير إلى المؤلفين، John Clauser وMichael
Horne وAbner Shimony وRichard Holt من ورقة بحثية عام 1969
حيث وُصف المثال
لأول مرة. لم يصفوه
كلعبة في الواقع، ومن الشائع جداً
الإشارة إلى هذا المثال
ليس بلعبة CHSH، بل
بمتباينة CHSH.
بالنسبة لعالم حاسوب مثلي، من الطبيعي جداً
وصفها كلعبة.
لقد أشرت بالفعل إلى أن
التجريدات الرياضية للألعاب مهمة ومفيدة على حد سواء وهناك العديد من الفئات المختلفة
للألعاب
التي يمكن دراستها. لعبة CHSH هي
مثال على فئة من الألعاب تُسمى الألعاب غير المحلية.
إليكم الإعداد بشكل عام
للعبة غير محلية.
لدينا لاعبان، Alice وBob، يتعاونان كفريق، فإما يفوزان معاً
أو يخسران معاً.
هذا يعني أنه ليس لديهما
حافز للتصرف بأنانية، فهذا في الأساس النقيض
التام لألعاب المجموع الصفري،
التي هي تنافسية بحتة، هنا اللعبة تعاونية بحتة.
هناك كيان ثالث يُسمى الحكم.
الحكم ليس لاعباً في اللعبة، بل الحكم
يدير اللعبة، وفي الواقع يمكنك التفكير في وصف
حالة معينة من لعبة
غير محلية ووصف الحكم
على أنهما متكافئان.
هناك قيد بالغ الأهمية يُفرض على Alice وBob، وهو أنه بمجرد بدء اللعبة، يُمنعان من
التواصل مع بعضهما.
يمكنهما الاتفاق مسبقاً على
أي استراتيجية يختارانها، لكن لا يُسمح بأي تواصل
بينهما أثناء اللعبة نفسها.
إذا أردت، يمكنك تخيل
أن اللعبة تجري في منشأة آمنة من نوع ما كما لو أن الحكم يلعب
دور المحقق
وAlice وBob مشتبه بهما في غرف مختلفة
في مركز شرطة، لكن طريقة أخرى
للتفكير في الإعداد
هي أن Alice وBob
مفصولان بمسافة شاسعة والتواصل ممنوع لأن سرعة الضوء
لا تسمح بالتواصل
بسرعة كافية. إذا حاولت Alice إرسال
رسالة إلى Bob مثلاً، ستكون اللعبة قد
انتهت بحلول وصولها إلى Bob.
طريقة عمل اللعبة غير
المحلية هي أن الحكم يسأل أولاً كلاً من
Alice وBob سؤالاً.
سؤال Alice يُرمز له بـ X وسؤال Bob يُرمز له بـ Y.
بشكل عام، يمكنك التفكير في X وY على أنهما حالات كلاسيكية
من أي حالات كلاسيكية تريدها وفي الحالة
المحددة للعبة CHSH،
X وY هما بتات.
يجب على Alice وBob تقديم إجابات، إجابة Alice يُرمز لها بـ A،
وإجابة Bob يُرمز لها بـ B،
ومرة أخرى، يمكن اعتبار هذه الإجابات حالات كلاسيكية بشكل عام ومثل الأسئلة، ستكون
بتات في لعبة CHSH.
عند هذه النقطة،
يتخذ الحكم قراراً، Alice وBob إما يفوزان أو يخسران حسب ما إذا كان
زوج الإجابات A وB
يُعتبر صحيحاً لزوج
الأسئلة X وY الذي طرحه الحكم، وسأقول المزيد
عن هذا بعد لحظة.
أولاً، دعونا نلقي
نظرة أقرب على الحكم لفهم ما هو
التحدي المحتمل لـ Alice وBob في لعبة غير محلية.
وما يجعل اللعبة غير المحلية
صعبة محتملاً هو أن الحكم يمكنه استخدام العشوائية لاختيار الأسئلة X وY.
هذا يعني أن Alice
وBob لديهما عدم يقين، لا يعرفان مسبقاً أي سؤال سيُطرح عليهما، وربما الأهم من ذلك،
لا يعرفان أي سؤال
تلقاه الآخر وعدم اليقين هذا
مع حقيقة أنهما لا يستطيعان التواصل
هو ما يشكل التحدي.
لذا، الأمر مشابه لحالة محقق
يستجوب مشتبهين في غرفتين مختلفتين، إذا
لم يكن المشتبهان يعرفان
ما هي الأسئلة المطروحة على الآخر، فمن الأصعب بكثير إذا كانا مذنبين أن يحافظا على اتساق روايتهما.
الآن، ذكرت منذ قليل
أن الحكم يحدد
ما إذا كان Alice وBob قد أجابا
بشكل صحيح أو خاطئ
بحسب الأسئلة
التي طُرحت عليهما.
يُفترض أن هذا
التحديد يتم وفقاً لقاعدة ثابتة
ويمكنك اعتبار أي قاعدة تريدها،
لكن أياً كانت،
يُفترض أن Alice
وBob يعرفان القاعدة، فعلى الأقل لديهما
فرصة للإجابة بشكل صحيح.
سنلقي نظرة على
القاعدة الخاصة بلعبة CHSH بعد قليل، لكن يمكننا
اعتبار قاعدة مختلفة وسيكون لدينا مثال مختلف
على لعبة غير محلية.
بعض الألعاب غير المحلية مثيرة للاهتمام وبعضها في الواقع مذهلة وغامضة حتى يومنا هذا و
بعضها ليس مثيراً للاهتمام،
هذه فقط طبيعة
نموذج الألعاب غير المحلية.
على أي حال، هذان هما الشيئان المختلفان المطلوبان لوصف الحكم؛ كيف يتم اختيار الأسئلة بالضبط
وأي أزواج إجابات صحيحة لكل زوج أسئلة ممكن.
إذا كان لدينا وصف
لهذين الشيئين، فلدينا وصف للحكم وهذا يصف فعلياً
حالة من لعبة غير محلية.
الآن دعونا نلقي نظرة
على لعبة CHSH بالتحديد.
طريقة تعريف اللعبة
أو بالتكافؤ، كيف يُعرّف الحكم هي كالتالي؛
أولاً، كما ذكرت بالفعل، الأسئلة والإجابات كلها بتات، فالحكم يرسل بت X
إلى Alice وبت Y إلى Bob،
وكل منهما يرد ببت. ترد Alice بـ A
ويرد Bob بـ B.
طريقة اختيار الحكم
للأسئلة بسيطة، يختارها
بشكل منتظم عشوائياً،
إذاً، زوج الأسئلة X وY من المرجح بالتساوي أن يكون أياً
من الاحتمالات الأربعة: صفر وصفر، صفر وواحد،
واحد وصفر، وواحد وواحد.
أخيراً، القاعدة التي
تحدد أي إجابات تفوز وأي إجابات تخسر هي
أن زوج الإجابات A وB صحيح لزوج الأسئلة X وY
إذا وفقط إذا كان الـ XOR لـ A وB يساوي الـ AND المنطقي لـ X وY.
قد يكون هذا أسهل في الاستيعاب إذا عبّرنا عن تلك الشروط
في شكل جدول كما ترون هنا.
في العمود الأول، لدينا أزواج الأسئلة الأربعة الممكنة، وفي العمود الثاني لدينا
الشروط على A وB
المطلوبة لفوز
Alice وBob.
في الحالات الثلاث الأولى،
الـ AND لـ X وY يساوي صفر، فيجب أن يكون الـ XOR مساوياً لصفر
لكي يفوزا،
وهذا نفس القول بأن A وB يجب أن يكونا متساويين لأن A وB بتات،
وفي الحالة الرابعة،
الـ AND لـ X وY يساوي
واحد ولذا يجب أن يكون الـ XOR لـ A وB مساوياً لواحد لكي يفوز Alice وBob
وهذا نفس القول
بأن A وB يجب أن يكونا مختلفين.
هذه إذاً هي لعبة CHSH، والآن يمكننا التفكير في
استراتيجيات مختلفة ممكنة لـ Alice وBob ومدى
جودة أدائهما في هذه اللعبة.
لنبدأ بالتفكير في
الاستراتيجيات الحتمية حيث إجابة Alice وهي A هي
دالة للسؤال X الذي تتلقاه، و
بالمثل، إجابة Bob وهي B
هي دالة للسؤال
Y الذي يتلقاه.
وكما يتبين، لا يمكن لأي
استراتيجية حتمية أن تفوز في كل مرة.
إحدى طرق الاستدلال على ذلك
هي ببساطة المرور واحدة تلو الأخرى على جميع
الاستراتيجيات الحتمية الممكنة والتحقق من أن كل واحدة منها تخسر
في واحد على الأقل من أزواج
الأسئلة الأربعة الممكنة.
Alice وBob كل منهما لديه
أربع دوال ممكنة للاختيار منها، رأينا تلك
الدوال الأربع في الدرس الأول، فهناك 16 احتمالاً
للتحقق منها إجمالاً.
طريقة أخرى لرؤية ذلك هي
التفكير في المعادلات هنا على الشاشة، نحن نفكر
في استراتيجيات حتمية
حيث A وB هما دالتان
لـ X وY على التوالي.
فمثلاً، A لصفر
تمثل إجابة Alice عندما يكون سؤالها X مساوياً لصفر وA لواحد تمثل إجابة Alice
عندما يكون سؤالها X مساوياً لواحد.
هذه هي المعادلات الأربع
التي يجب أن تكون صحيحة لكي تتحقق شروط
الفوز في كل من الحالات الأربع.
مثلاً، إذا كان X مساوياً
لصفر وY مساوياً لصفر، فيجب أن يكون الـ XOR لـ A
وB مساوياً لصفر،
بينما في حالة أن X مساوٍ لواحد وY مساوٍ لواحد، يجب أن يكون
الـ XOR لـ A وB مساوياً لواحد.
إحدى الطرق لنرى أنه
لا توجد طريقة لاختيار الدالتين A وB بحيث
تكون هذه المعادلات كلها صحيحة، هي ببساطة أخذ الـ XOR
لجميع المعادلات.
الـ XOR لأي قيمة
ثنائية مع نفسها يساوي صفر، وبالتالي يترتب على ذلك أن الـ XOR
لجميع الطرفين الأيسرين
يساوي صفر، وذلك
لأن لدينا حالتين من A لصفر، وحالتين من A لواحد،
وحالتين من B لصفر
وحالتين من B لواحد.
لذا، بأخذ الـ XOR لها جميعاً
نحصل على النتيجة النهائية صفر، لكن إذا أخذنا الـ XOR للطرفين الأيمنين من المعادلات،
نحصل على واحد وليس صفر. فالمعادلات الأربع
لا يمكن أن تكون كلها صحيحة، واحدة على الأقل يجب أن تكون خاطئة
وهذا سيؤدي إلى
خسارة Alice وBob في واحدة على الأقل من الحالات الأربع.
وبالتالي يترتب على ذلك لأن الحكم يختار الأسئلة
بشكل منتظم أن احتمال فوز Alice وBob
باستخدام استراتيجية حتمية
هو على الأكثر ثلاثة أرباع أو 75%.
حقيقة أن Alice وBob يمكنهما الفوز باحتمال ثلاثة أرباع سهلة الرؤية
في الواقع، إذا أجاب Alice وBob بصفر طوال
الوقت مثلاً،
سيكونان على صواب ثلاث
مرات من أصل أربع.
إذاً Alice وBob لا يمكنهما
أن يفعلا أفضل من الفوز بنسبة 75% من الوقت باستخدام
استراتيجية حتمية.
لكن ماذا عن الاستراتيجية الاحتمالية؟
حسناً، يتبين أن استخدام
استراتيجية احتمالية لا يمكن أن يساعدهما على الإطلاق، وذلك لأن كل
استراتيجية احتمالية
يمكن بدلاً من ذلك اعتبارها
اختياراً عشوائياً لاستراتيجية حتمية تماماً كما يمكن اعتبار العمليات
الاحتمالية
اختيارات عشوائية
للعمليات الحتمية، كما رأينا في الدرس الأول.
المتوسط لا يكون أبداً
أكبر من الحد الأقصى، فيترتب على ذلك أن
الاستراتيجية الاحتمالية لا تقدم أي ميزة
من حيث الفوز
على الاستراتيجية الحتمية. هذا يشمل حتى احتمال أن الاختيارات العشوائية لـ Alice وBob
مرتبطة.
إذاً، الخلاصة هي أن الفوز باحتمال ثلاثة أرباع هو أفضل ما يمكن أن يحققه Alice
وBob باستخدام أي استراتيجية كلاسيكية،
سواء كانت حتمية
أو احتمالية.
السؤال الطبيعي الذي يُطرح في هذه المرحلة هو ما إذا كان بإمكان Alice وBob تحقيق أداء أفضل باستخدام استراتيجية كمية،
وبالتحديد
إذا كانا يتشاركان حالة كمية متشابكة أعداها
قبل لعب اللعبة، فهل يمكن أن يساعدهما ذلك؟
الإجابة هي نعم، يمكن ذلك، وهذا هو الهدف من المثال وهذا ما يجعله مثيراً للاهتمام.
فلنر بالضبط كيف
يمكن لـ Alice وBob تحقيق أداء أفضل في هذه اللعبة باستخدام التشابك.
أول شيء نحتاج لفعله هو تعريف متجه حالة كمية Chi
theta لكل زاوية theta، كما ترون هنا على الشاشة.
إذاً، Chi theta يساوي
جيب التمام لـ theta مضروباً في حالة الصفر زائد جيب theta مضروباً في حالة
الواحد، وهنا بالمناسبة،
نفكر في الزوايا
بالراديان.
فمثلاً، هذا هو المتجه الذي نحصل عليه عندما تكون theta مساوية لـ pi على
أربعة، وهي 45 درجة.
جيب التمام لـ pi على أربعة
وجيب pi على أربعة كلاهما يساوي واحد على
الجذر التربيعي للاثنين، فهذا مجرد اسم
آخر لحالة الزائد.
إليكم مثالاً آخر عندما تكون theta مساوية لثلاثة مضروبة في pi على ثمانية، وفي حال لم تكن
تعرف الجيب
وجيب التمام لثلاثة مضروبة في pi على ثمانية من رأسك،
إليكم جدولاً للجيوب وجيوب التمام التي سنحتاجها
فعلاً
خلال هذا المثال
ويتضمن تلك التي نحتاجها لهذا المتجه بالذات.
الآن، إذا أردنا حساب حاصل الضرب الداخلي بين أي متجهين من هذه المتجهات
للزوايا alpha وbeta لنقل، فمن
السهل فعل ذلك.
لدينا فقط أرقام حقيقية
كمدخلات في هذه المتجهات فلا توجد مرافقات عقدية
للقلق بشأنها ونحصل على حاصل ضرب جيبي التمام
زائد حاصل ضرب الجيبين، ويمكننا استخدام واحدة من
ما يُسمى بصيغ جمع الزوايا
لتبسيط ذلك، إنه جيب
التمام للفرق بين الزاويتين
ولأن دالة جيب التمام
متماثلة حول الصفر،
لا يهم فعلاً بأي ترتيب نأخذهما.
إذا لم تكن هذه المتطابقات
المثلثية محفوظة في ذاكرتك،
بالمناسبة، فلست وحدك، لكن لا تحتاج لتذكرها،
يمكنك ببساطة البحث عنها. هذه المتطابقة منطقية
رغم ذلك عندما تفكر في التفسير الهندسي
لحاصل الضرب الداخلي
بين متجهات وحدة حقيقية كجيب التمام للزاوية بينهما.
إذا حسبنا حاصل الضرب
الداخلي لحاصل الضرب التنسوري لأي متجهين من هذه المتجهات
مع حالة Phi plus، نحصل على تعبير مشابه
لكن مع جذر تربيعي
للاثنين في المقام.
هذه أول مرة
تظهر فيها حالة Phi plus في سياق
هذا المثال بالمناسبة، وسنرى بالضبط لماذا نهتم
بحاصل الضرب الداخلي هذا بالذات قريباً، لكن في الوقت الحالي دعونا
فقط نلاحظ أننا نحصل على نفس التعبير الذي كان لدينا
لحاصل الضرب الداخلي مقسوماً
على الجذر التربيعي للاثنين وبالتالي يمكننا التبسيط كما فعلنا سابقاً.
بعد ذلك، سنعرّف
مصفوفة أحادية، U theta، لكل زاوية theta
كما ترون هنا،
ليس من الصعب
التحقق من أن هذه مصفوفة أحادية فعلاً.
الشيء الأساسي الذي نحتاج
لإدراكه هو أن المتجه Chi theta متعامد مع
المتجه Chi theta زائد pi على اثنين، وهذا منطقي
لأنه إذا دوّرنا بمقدار pi على اثنين، وهو 90 درجة،
نحصل على متجه متعامد.
إذا ضربنا بعد ذلك U
theta في U theta المرافقة، نحصل على مصفوفة الهوية.
حدسياً،
ما تفعله هذه المصفوفة كعملية هو
ربط Chi theta بحالة الصفر وChi theta زائد pi على اثنين بحالة الواحد.
عند هذه النقطة، لدينا
كل ما نحتاجه لوصف استراتيجية Alice وBob.
أولاً، تماماً كما كان الحال في النقل الآني والترميز فائق الكثافة، سيبدأ Alice وBob بمشاركة e-bit.
Alice تحمل qubit A،
وBob يحمل qubit B، ومعاً الـ qubit الاثنان
في حالة Phi plus.
أفعال Alice هي كالتالي؛ تنظر إلى البت X الذي
تتلقاه من الحكم،
وإذا كان X مساوياً لصفر،
تطبق U صفر على A، وهو ما يكافئ
عدم فعل شيء لأن U صفر هي مصفوفة الهوية،
وإذا كان X مساوياً لواحد من ناحية أخرى، تطبق U pi على أربعة على A.
بعد أن تطبق إحدى
العمليتين، تقيس A باستخدام قياس
الأساس القياسي وترسل أي نتيجة
تحصل عليها إلى الحكم.
Bob يفعل شيئاً مشابهاً جداً، الـ qubit الخاص به يُسمى B بالطبع، ويتلقى Y من
الحكم بدلاً من X
لكن الفرق الرئيسي هو
أنه يستخدم زوايا مختلفة لعملياته الأحادية.
إذا كان Y مساوياً لصفر، يطبق
U pi على ثمانية، وإذا كان Y مساوياً لواحد، يطبق U سالب pi على ثمانية.
وسنرى لماذا هذه الاختيارات للزوايا هي اختيارات جيدة قريباً،
الأمر ليس واضحاً على الإطلاق.
وإليكم مخطط circuit
يعبّر عن هذه الاستراتيجية.
Bob في الأعلى وAlice
في الأسفل هذه المرة، وهنا الـ e-bit القادمة
وهذه هي الـ gate الأحادية
التي قد يطبقها أو لا يطبقها Alice وBob
حسب قيمة X وY.
لهذه وتلك، لدينا gate يتحكم بها إما البت X أو البت Y
ولهاتين هنا، لدينا ما يشبه
gate تحكم إلا أن الدائرة غير مملوءة.
وما يعنيه هذا هو
أنه إذا كان بت التحكم مضبوطاً على صفر، تُنفذ الـ gate وإذا كان التحكم مضبوطاً على
واحد، لا يحدث شيء.
إذاً، إنها تماماً مثل
gate تحكم عادية إلا أن دورَي الصفر والواحد للتحكم مبدّلان.
إذاً، فعلياً، Bob
يطبق هذه الـ gate هنا إذا كان Y مساوياً لصفر، و
يطبق هذه الـ gate هنا
إذا كان Y مساوياً لواحد، وبالمثل، تطبق Alice هذه الـ gate
هنا إذا كان X مساوياً لصفر، وهذه الـ gate هنا،
إذا كان X مساوياً لواحد.
هذه إذاً هي استراتيجية Alice وBob والآن نحتاج فقط
لمعرفة مدى نجاحها.
لتحليل الاستراتيجية الكمية التي وصفتها للتو،
نحتاج فعلاً فقط إلى شيئين في هذه المرحلة، أولاً،
المصفوفة الأحادية U Theta
كما ترونها هنا، و
ثانياً كانت لدينا هذه الصيغة.
لا نحتاج فعلاً حتى لتعريف المتجه Chi theta بعد الآن، هاتان المعادلتان هما كل ما نحتاجه.
هناك أربع حالات
للنظر فيها بدءاً بالحالة الأولى، وهي أن X يساوي
صفر وY يساوي صفر.
وإذا نظرنا إلى الاستراتيجية، سنجد أنه في هذه
الحالة تطبق Alice U صفر على الـ qubit الخاص بها وBob يطبق
U pi على ثمانية على الـ qubit الخاص به.
تذكر، Alice في الأسفل
وBob في الأعلى، فالحالة التي
يحصلان عليها تبدو هكذا.
وبتوسيع ذلك
وفقاً لتعريف U theta، نحصل على هذا
التعبير الذي ترونه هنا.
لا نحتاج لتوسيع
ذلك أكثر لأن لدينا الصيغة
الأخرى لمساعدتنا.
وإذا طبقنا تلك الصيغة
لكل من الحدود الأربعة، ما نحصل عليه هو هذا.
عند هذه النقطة يقيس Alice وBob كلاهما وإليكم جدولاً
يشرح توزيع النتائج.
نأخذ القيمة المطلقة
المربعة للمعاملات للحصول على الاحتمالات، وهي تصادف أن تكون
مربعات المعاملات
لأن المعاملات كلها
أرقام حقيقية في هذه الحالة.
إذا استخدمنا قيم
الجيب وجيب التمام من وقت سابق في الدرس
مع بعض التماثلات، يمكننا التعبير عن هذه الاحتمالات
كما لدينا هنا
في العمود الأخير.
الآن، ما يهمنا حقاً
هو احتمال الفوز، وتذكر أنه في حالة أن X وY كلاهما صفر،
يفوزان إذا كان A وB متساويين ويخسران إذا كان A وB غير متساويين.
إذا حسبنا تلك الاحتمالات، نجد أن احتمال
أن A وB متساويان هو مجموع هذا الرقم وهذا الرقم،
والذي يساوي اثنين زائد
الجذر التربيعي للاثنين الكل على أربعة، وهو تقريباً 85%.
احتمال أن A وB غير متساويين هو اثنين ناقص الجذر التربيعي للاثنين الكل على أربعة، وهو بطبيعة الحال واحد ناقص الكمية
التي حسبناها للتو،
فيفوزان باحتمال تقريباً 85% في هذه الحالة.
هناك ثلاث حالات أخرى للنظر فيها، لكنها كلها مشابهة جداً لهذه،
في حالة أن X يساوي
صفر وY يساوي واحد، يطبق Bob U سالب pi على ثمانية بدلاً من U pi على ثمانية،
القيم في
الصيغ تتغير بعض الشيء، لكننا ننتهي بنفس
الاحتمالات التي كانت لدينا في الحالة السابقة بالضبط.
عندما X يساوي صفر وY يساوي واحد، لا يزال Alice وBob يفوزان
عندما يكون A وB متساويين وبالتالي لدينا نفس احتمال
الفوز بالضبط
كما كان سابقاً.
في الحالة الثالثة، عندما X يساوي واحد وY يساوي صفر،
لدينا حالة مشابهة، الزوايا مختلفة،
لكن لها بالضبط
نفس العلاقة
مع بعضها البعض، وفي الواقع، نحصل بالضبط على
نفس المتجه الذي حصلنا عليه في الحالة السابقة.
فالاحتمالات هي نفسها وكذلك احتمال الفوز.
الحالة الأخيرة مختلفة قليلاً
كما قد نتوقع لأن شرط الفوز
مختلف في هذه الحالة.
عندما يكون X وY كلاهما مساوياً لواحد، يفوز Alice وBob عندما
يكون A وB مختلفين.
الطريقة الأساسية هي نفسها، رغم أن الزوايا مختلفة، هذه المرة نحصل على هذا المتجه هنا
ويمكنك التحقق من ذلك بالمرور بعمليات الطرح المطلوبة.
الاحتمالات تتغير أخيراً، وإذا بحثنا عن القيم التي نحتاجها، نرى أن الاحتمالات
قد تبادلت
مواقعها عن السابق، فهذه المرة احتمال
أن A لا يساوي B هو الأكبر من الاثنين،
لكن هذا جيد لأنه في هذه الحالة، يفوز Alice وBob عندما
يكون A وB غير متساويين.
فمرة أخرى، يفوزان باحتمال
تقريباً 85%.
بالنظر إلى أنهما يفوزان في كل
حالة بنفس الاحتمال، وهو اثنين زائد الجذر التربيعي للاثنين
الكل على أربعة أو تقريباً 85%،
فهذا هو الاحتمال
الذي يفوزان به إجمالاً.
هذا أفضل مما يمكن لأي استراتيجية كلاسيكية تحقيقه في هذه اللعبة، وهذا
ما يجعلها مثيرة للاهتمام.
هذا يصادف أنه
الاحتمال الأمثل للفوز لأي استراتيجية كمية، لا
يمكنك تحقيق أفضل من هذا باستخدام أي حالة متشابكة.
هذه الحقيقة تُعرف بمتباينة Tsirelson، سُميت على اسم Boris
Tsirelson الذي أثبتها أولاً، وحسب علمي كان
من أوائل الأشخاص
الذين وصفوا هذا المثال كلعبة. في حال بدا التحليل
الذي مررنا به للتو غامضاً بعض الشيء،
من الممكن التفكير
فيه هندسياً، وهو ما قد يساعد
في إعطائك فهماً أفضل لاختيار الزوايا.
بالتحديد، إذا استخدمنا
الصيغة التي ترونها هنا، والتي يمكننا استنتاجها بسهولة
من التعبيرات
التي وجدناها بالفعل لحواصل
الضرب الداخلي المعنية، فيمكننا بدلاً من ذلك
التعبير عن احتمالات نتائج القياس
المختلفة الممكنة
في الحالات الأربع كالتالي؛ أولاً، إذا كان X وY يساويان صفر وصفر، فهذه هي الاحتمالات
لنتائج القياس المختلفة، وعليك إما أن تتذكر أو ترجع إلى التحليل
الذي مررنا به للتو لتستنتج ذلك باستخدام صيغتنا.
هنا، يمكننا رؤية
متجهات الحالة المختلفة مرسومة كما كانت سابقاً، والترميز اللوني هنا
هو أن الأزرق يتوافق
مع النتيجة صفر والأحمر
يتوافق مع النتيجة واحد.
يمكنك ملاحظة أن الزاوية
بين المتجهات الزرقاء والزاوية بين المتجهات
الحمراء صغيرة نسبياً،
إنها pi على ثمانية في كلتا الحالتين، فجيب التمام كبير نسبياً، وهذا يعني أن
احتمال أن النتيجتين
متساويتان كبير نسبياً.
في حالة أن X وY يساويان صفر وواحد، الوضع مشابه،
الزوايا بين المتجهات التي لها نفس اللون صغيرة،
فاحتمال النتائج
المتساوية أيضاً كبير نسبياً.
الحالة الثالثة مشابهة، وفي الحالة الرابعة
عندما X وY يساويان واحد وواحد، يحدث شيء مثير للاهتمام،
هذه المرة، فقط بحكم الطريقة
التي اختيرت بها هذه المتجهات، نرى أن الزوايا بين
المتجهات التي لها نفس اللون
كبيرة نسبياً، وتحديداً الزوايا هي ثلاثة مضروبة في
pi على ثمانية في كلتا الحالتين.
هذا يعني أن احتمال
أن نتائج القياس متساوية صغير نسبياً، لكن هذه هي الحالة الوحيدة
التي يفوز فيها Alice وBob
عندما تختلف إجاباتهما،
فهذا ما نريده.
مرة أخرى، إليكم المتجهات: عندما X وY يساويان صفر وصفر،
وعندما X وY يساويان صفر وواحد،
وعندما X وY يساويان واحد وصفر،
وعندما X وY يساويان واحد وواحد.
وربما هذه الصورة الهندسية
مفيدة في بناء بعض الحدس
لكيفية عمل هذه الاستراتيجية
ولماذا اختيرت هذه الزوايا المختلفة بالطريقة التي اختيرت بها.
لإنهاء الدرس، سأقدم بعض الملاحظات المختصرة
عن لعبة CHSH.
أولاً، كما ذكرت بالفعل، هذا المثال لا يُوصف دائماً
كلعبة.
في مجتمع الفيزياء مثلاً، من الأشيع أن
يُوصف المثال ببساطة كتجربة بدلاً من لعبة
ويُنظر إلى Alice وBob
على أنهما كاشفان بدلاً من لاعبين.
الفكرة الأساسية لتجربة كهذه حيث يؤدي التشابك
إلى نتائج إحصائية غير متوافقة مع
أي وصف كلاسيكي
أو بشكل أعم أي
نظرية مبنية على ما يُسمى بالمتغيرات الخفية المحلية،
تعود إلى John Bell، الذي سُميت حالات Bell باسمه،
ولذلك كثيراً ما يشير الناس
إلى تجارب من هذا النوع باختبارات Bell.
أحياناً يشير الناس أيضاً
إلى نظرية Bell، التي يمكن صياغتها بطرق مختلفة، لكنها تقول بشكل أساسي
إن ميكانيكا الكم
غير متوافقة مع ما يُسمى بنظريات المتغيرات الخفية المحلية.
لعبة أو متباينة CHSH هي في الأساس مثال أنيق ونظيف جداً
لاختبار Bell،
ويمكنك التفكير في
هذا المثال كبرهان أو عرض لنظرية Bell.
الملاحظة الثانية هي أن لعبة CHSH تقدم لنا طريقة لاختبار أن نظرية المعلومات الكمية تجريبياً
هي نظرية دقيقة. يمكننا فعلاً إعداد تجارب تنفذ لعبة CHSH،
بما في ذلك نوع
الاستراتيجية المبنية على التشابك التي وصفتها للتو، و
نرى إن كانت تعمل، وهي تعمل فعلاً.
هذا يمنحنا درجة عالية
من الثقة بأن التشابك حقيقي، وعلى عكس الطرق
الغامضة أو الشاعرية ربما
التي نحاول ابتكارها
لشرح التشابك، تعطينا لعبة أو تجربة CHSH
طريقة ملموسة
وقابلة للاختبار لملاحظة التشابك.
إذا بدا ذلك مهماً،
فذلك لأنه كذلك، وجائزة نوبل في الفيزياء
لعام 2022 تعترف بهذا بالضبط.
مُنحت الجائزة لـ
Alain Aspect وJohn Clauser، وهو حرف C في CHSH، وAnton Zeilinger
عن تجارب مع فوتونات متشابكة أثبتت انتهاك
متباينات Bell، أو بعبارة أخرى،
أظهرت أن الاستراتيجيات الكمية
من النوع الذي وصفته تعمل فعلاً وتتفوق على الاستراتيجيات الكلاسيكية.
وإذا كنت مهتماً بمعرفة
المزيد عن هذا، أشجعك على مشاهدة
الفيديو عن نظرية Bell من إعداد زميلتي Olivia Lanes،
هنا على قناة Qiskit على يوتيوب.
وأخيراً، موضوع الألعاب
غير المحلية بشكل أعم هو موضوع مذهل حقاً، وهو
مجال بحث نشط
يجمع بين الفيزياء
وعلوم الحاسوب والرياضيات البحتة وهناك لا تزال العديد من
الأسئلة المثيرة للاهتمام
حول الألعاب غير المحلية التي
لم تُجب عنها حتى يومنا هذا.
وهذه نهاية الدرس الرابع، وكذلك نهاية
الوحدة الأولى من السلسلة حول أساسيات المعلومات الكمية.
شرح الدرس الأول
كيفية عمل المعلومات الكمية للأنظمة المفردة بمعزل، وشرح الدرس الثاني
كيفية عمل المعلومات الكمية
للأنظمة المتعددة،
والتي تنشأ بشكل طبيعي جداً من كيفية عملها للأنظمة المفردة.
قدّم الدرس الثالث
نموذج circuit الكمية للحوسبة، وفي الدرس الرابع، ألقينا نظرة على ثلاثة أمثلة مهمة
توضح أشياء يمكننا
فعلها بالتشابك.
وفي أثناء ذلك، رأينا بعض المفاهيم الرياضية المهمة جداً،
بما في ذلك حواصل الضرب التنسوري وحواصل الضرب الداخلي، ولاحظنا
بعض القيود الأساسية
للمعلومات الكمية.
آمل أن تنضموا إليّ في
الوحدة التالية من السلسلة، والتي ستكون عن الخوارزميات الكمية، حيث سنركز على سؤال
ما هي المزايا الحسابية
التي تقدمها المعلومات الكمية.
إلى اللقاء حتى ذلك الحين.